Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Subnautica!
Now, we found the island! And, I mean wow, this is like, totally cool,
but at the same time, I've got a lot of stuff that I need to do.
I need to figure out a way to make a base here using all the supplies that I have in my base,
about a thousand meters away.
And I farmed up a lot of CRAP, and it's all the way in the base
in the lockers that has you guys's name on it!
And I haven't picked any more names because I'm still recording in the same session as before,
so what I'm gunna do now, for right now, and I know that I said I was gunna build a base on here,
but I don't have the materials to do that,
and I don't have the time to farm it all up.
SO, we're gunna shelve that, FOR NOW, we'll pick it up in the next episode,
but, for now, I really really really, REALLY, REALLY wanna find out what's in this cave opening.
So, in order to do that, I need to get, the, uh, Terraf-Terraformer? what was it-
Terraformer? Yeah, Terraformer!
I need to make a Terraformer,
That'll allow me to change up the environment enough, that I'll be able to get what I need in that cave opening--
--If I can get to that cave opening!
I don't know if I can, because it seems to be directly below me right here,
over a thousand meters below the surface.
and...I don't know how to get that, because that sounds nigh on impossible!
But, I'm always up for a challenge!
So, we're gunna get there, I will be right back after I get the terraformer,
and I'll see you, at--th--nngh-near entrance of this--possible cave opening
deep, beneath, the ocean.
OK, so we now have: the terraformer!
And, I don't know why I put my KNIFE AWAY cuz I'm a big dumdoodoooo!
And--If you guys can let me know, is there any way to repair the thermo blade,
because I still have it, it's still here, it's just it's at a durability of zero
so if there's a way to repair that, lemme know, I would like TO know,
and we'll see what we can do about that.
OH!
OH that's amazing!
Heh, I didn't know that it'd [heh]
Woah, I can build my own island, apparently!
Wow, that is....
Ahhhh, that looks scary. And weird.
But, OK, it's effective! It's surprisingly effective!
So I've got 25 "MATERIAL" and now I'munna be able to get down to that cave opening
Also, there's a geological formation over there,
ALSO....there's a Heat Signature? That I found--
Wait, where is--where is uh, John Smith!
There's a Heat Signature. This...right here.
It's a Heat Signature, I don't know what that means, that might just be an area where there's volcanic activity
and if I go to there I'm unna just gunna find a volcano and I'm unna burn alive
FUCK A DUCK DOCK
duh-
Fuck a Duck
time to go
OK, so we're gunna find--it's right down there
now I could--I could literally just dig through the uh--through the ocean floor and get to there
but, I'm not gunna dooo dat, I'm unna--What is this?
[gasp]
Wait-
I-
I've never noticed this before!
Was this always here?
Waaaaaait a minute--Waaait a minute, wait--
This can't be, this must be the same cave system as leading to the other one, right?
[gasp] NO, IT'S NOT! Oooh, my gah-OH AH
GETTING OUT OF HERE!
NO! NONONO
NONONONONONO
Yer not gunna trick me!
Ya bitch!
Ya sassy BITCH!
Y'ain't gunna trick me.
BUT, this could lead down deeper...
and I do not know what the maximum depth of these caves are,
And these could lead, way way way WAY down and I just don't know it.
But I have a funny feeling that it's not quite that simple.
OK, so, I'm unna be right back, I'm unna find...
I'munna find the right place to go for this
but I don't know if I'munna find it right away.
Wow. Holy Crap--
Wow!
Wow that is! That is shocklingly effective!
That--
uh--
I mean--
Woah
I mean literally, WOAH
That is--Wow!
That-That just--WOW!
That--W-w-what the hell--That just--
[Angelic singing in background]
That is so effective it-it made a choir of angels sing at the capacity for my power!
Woo-hooh!
Now, I'm just tryina get a--a nice path for my Seamoth to go through
Wo-a--I did not realize that the Terraformer was--THAT effective!
Holy crap! That is...
Woah...
I-I guess--I guess I legitimately am just going to start... Burrowing down.
This is gunna take a while.
This is legitimately gunna take a while!
and I do not know if this is the most effective strategy, but hey!
It's the best I got for now!
And it's...it's workin.
Just takin' a while.
Yep. I broke it.
I think I ran out of material that I can absorb? Maybe? In my Terraformer?
Which would be perfectly understandable considering how--Frikkin much--I did this
So I'm unna go try to deposit this and,
in doing so, I think I'm unna make a mountain.
I'm pretty sure I'm unna make a brand new mountain outta all of this.
But, oh well--Oh man!
I just made the scariest tunnel--that I could possibly imagine.
I am--the evil wyrm that lives in my nightmares!
I am! the underwater monstrosity that eats through the entire planet!
I am! The Terror! In the night!
And I am--gunna dump my shit....
and block up that vent. Cause, fuck that.
Oh!
Hey, woah!
Hey woah heyyy woahh
You wanna dance with me? I'll bury ya in a frikkin...Whatever!
Don't mess with me, bro.
Scary.
I CONTROL POWERS OF WHICH YOU CANNOT COMPREHEND!
YOU DARE DEFITTLE WITH ME???
I AM THE ONE WHO FIDDLES!
...With reality?
I'm never gunna be able to remember where this cave entrance is
cuz it's tiny.
Dere it is!
Dere's da secret portal to hell!
I mean, admittedly, I haven't made that much progress coming down here?
I could probably be a LITTLE more--
I don't have to make it this wide! is what I'm saying
I don't! I can be more sparing with it and I can go farther
straight down instead of carving such a rounded path.
Oh! Apparently I--done goofed. And...
it doesn't like me anymore.
Wow, i-it doesn't want me to terraform beyond that-point. Okay!
Alright, I gotchya, ok, I-I-I get it, I get it, I get it, I get it, I git it, I git it, I'm breakin the game, I get it!
I get it.
Y-That's not how this goes!
What I did was not Kosher!
I should have understood that when I made the portal to hell!
that is this tunnel!
I get it--OK!
So the game does not like me doing that!
That was NOT a good idea, I need to find the entrance to this cave a little bit better!
I need to not be so stupid about it!
Which is a--I-I-I get it! I understand! I-I'm an agreeable guy!
I-I kind of understand the concept of which-with-it-w-wi-which you're speaking.
So I'm unna go out, and I'm unna find another way around.
That's the nature of the game.
What're you?
Are you an entrance to a caave?
eugh
You're filled with disgusting horrible creatures but you don't look like an entrance.
[Karen] Caution: Mild dehydration dectected.
Dammit.
Ahhhhhhhhhh, STUPID HUMAN BODY NEEDS!
Apparently, the game doesn't like me cheating my way to the bottom,
so I gotta find a way to do it legitimately.
In the vain attempt to getting down below the ocean floor--Which is not going well for me--
there MUST be a way to get to that cave opening that I'm not understanding.
It could be, like, a way out of the way path that takes me to the side that goes slanted down
and I need to find that entrance?
But the possibility for me finding THAT is VERY slim.
Maybe--Thiiis?
I don't think this is it.
Uhhhhhhhhh,
oooh there's something over here but I don't think it's a cave opening
it's just to the disgusting, ok, that's the other side of the disgusting, OK.
So I'm unna go try to find whatever the hell is Geological Formation is.
It seems pretty deep... Underwater... Pretty far away...
And I think I'm about to traverse into Reaper terratory but this might! give me a clue to something else!
It wouldn't point me at it, if it wasn't something significant!
Heck, it gave me something as significant as a... Frikkin...
LAND MASS, the only island in the game!
It was just outta nowhere!
It was kind of sittin there where everyone could find it.
Not exactly secret at all!
I guess no one's lookin up.
That's the thing.
Well, actually, this is looking very weird!
I don't...recognize...this...land area...
Huh.
Wheeeeeeeeeeeeere is this?
I don't remember any of this.
This might very well be serious Reaper terratory,
cuz this seems to be the area behind the--Aurora.
[Ominous choir music]
--And the ominous choir music is pickin up again b'cause, I'm assuming--
Oh my god, is this where that Emperor thing is??
[GASP]
Ooo...
Where the heck is this?
Oh, okay
We're just in bulbous territory, I've been to Bulbous!
I don't know what the geological formation--
OH!
Maybe it's talkin about the thing that I already found!
Because I did find that weird cave system down here before
I think this is it--Yeah, I think that is...It.
This really bizzare geolotical--
--Wait actually
Wait, did I see this? Woah!
That is weird!
OK! I'll admit, this is interesting!
It's a giant rock that's standing on a tiny crevace like that!
Pretty cool! I-I-I mean I'm not gunna DENY it's pretty cool but why did I come out here?
Is there a way to destroy this?
So that was a bust, so I'm-uh-going to take the Heat Signature--
Which I imagine! I imagine--
I actuallly looked it up, I just looked it up on my phone,
and apparently other people are having trouble finding this too--
Wow I am VERY close to that.
What heat signature are you?
Are you talkin about the volcanic vents under--
You ARE talkin--
I ALREADY FOUND THIS!
I ALREADY MARVELLED AT IT!
OOH! AHH! LOOK AT THAT!
LIFE IS HAPPENING!
WELL CRAFTED ENVIRONMENTS 'N' SHIT!
I already BEEN THERE I already DONE THAT
I already was excited 'bout it
I ain't gunna be excited AGAIN!
Hokay!
So!
Unfortunately, this episode was a bit of a bust.
I didn't get everything accomplished that I wanted to accomplish--
I THOUGHT I was on the right track digging deep underground--
It MAY have just bugged out--it MAY have just bugged out
and, y'know, could've been somethin' else about that, I mean,
This is NOT very obvious where it wants me to go for this possible cave opening,
I WIIISH I could FIIND IT!!
and maybe
I'm just gunna have to spend a bunch of time off camera just
DIGGING in the dirt as fast as I caaan
Tryina clear away a big path, maybe that's it, maybe it just bugged out in that particular direction.
But, I'munna find it!
I'munna do my best!
And we're gunna get there,
we WILL get there and if any of you know, please write in the comments down below,
letting me know,
where to go for these things.
THAT--
--wait. wuh?
HEY!
THERE WAS SOMETHIN THERE!
You can't-brh-uh--God dammit.
That was a piece for the Cyclops.
So anyway,
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
Lemme know, how to do that
and what you'd like to see in the next video of Subnautica, in the comments below!
Thanks again, everybody!
And as always, I will see you...
IN the next video!
BUH BYE!!!